- [Announcer] A Corona
virus vaccine is seen
as a key weapon against the pandemic,
but how much will shots cost in the US?
Some companies have said
that a dose could sell
for as little as a few
bucks to as much as $25.
And that vaccines may actually
be available fairly quickly
by industry standards,
meaning less than two years,
as opposed to more than 10.
- It's called operation warp speed.
That means big. And it means fast.
- [Announcer] Of more
than 160 groups racing
to put a vaccine on the market,
a handful entered the final testing stage
within the first six months.
That's much faster than the usual process,
which can take years.
And that's in part thanks
to US government money.
The administration handed
out more than $10 billion
between March and August.
- There's an expectation on the
public's part that the drug,
because it's been funded
partially by tax payer money,
that the price will be reasonable.
- [Announcer] But investors
have also poured funds
into drug makers and stocks
at some pharma companies have sought.
That's putting pressure on big pharma
to make vaccines affordable
while also keeping investors happy.
We wanted to know what does that mean
for the final price tag?
Developing a vaccine is a huge gamble.
Getting it from the lab to
clinic can cost billions
of dollars and not all
of the companies that
are developing vaccines will
end up with a viable product.
- Of all of the vaccines
that start human testing,
about 66% of them will fail.
- Kenneth Kaitin studies drug pricing
at Tufts Center for the
Study of Drug Development,
which receives grants from
the pharmaceutical industry.
He says vaccine R&D is something
few companies can afford.
- Not a lot of companies
actually invest in this
for a variety of reasons.
One of them is the poor
likelihood of success
and the difficulty of generating revenue
on whatever R&D activity they have.
- [Announcer] But in the case
of the COVID-19 pandemic,
government money is taking
away a lot of that risk
by funding, vaccine
research and development
and signing contracts to
buy the vaccines before
they're even approved.
Two government deals with
Moderna and Pfizer would secure
as many as 200 million
doses by January next year.
And that would mean both
vaccines would be free of charge
to people in the US at least initially.
To speed things up, pharma companies
received additional
funds for manufacturing
and are already mass producing vaccines
while still conducting clinical trials.
Michael Kinch is a biochemistry professor
and a vaccine historian.
He says producing and storing vaccines
can be very expensive.
- Under what conditions, what
the temperatures and humidity
and a number of things that, again,
oftentimes can take years to develop.
It might be that we find out
that certain conditions
ruin a batch of vaccine.
- There's also a parallel
scramble to secure billions
of medical grade vials
and syringes that are just
as important as clinical trials.
And the US isn't the only country trying
to secure doses for its citizens.
- Certainly there are
just 7 billion people,
which is probably an underestimate,
and if each one perhaps needs two doses,
you're talking about a
monumental logistics challenge
of being able to create
double digit billions
of different vaccine doses.
- Manufacturers of glass
vials have estimated
that worldwide demand
because of the pandemic
will increase by 2 billion
over the next two years.
Since most of the medical
supplies are sourced overseas,
the US government is giving
American glass-makers
and syringe suppliers, federal contracts
to ramp up production.
Some Americans are hesitant
about taking a COVID-19 vaccine
because of concerns that
development is being rushed.
To allay those concerns,
several industry rivals
are planning a joint pledge to
not seek regulatory approval
until the shots are proven
to be safe and effective.
Despite the hurdles, some
companies are joining
the crowded race because they already have
the technical capabilities to do so.
For instance, Novavax says
it makes business sense
to repurpose the technology it uses for
a promising flu vaccine to
develop one for COVID-19.
Plus financial backing from
not just the US government,
but also various countries and nonprofits
have also given companies
more of an incentive to chip
in than ever before.
In return, companies may get
positive coverage worldwide
for stepping in during a pandemic
or being one of those to
find an effective vaccine.
Lawmakers have said that drug makers
should be held accountable
to taxpayer dollars.
Some companies have said their vaccines
will be priced at cost
because of the current crisis.
- We will be providing a vaccine
at a not-for-profit price
during the emergency pandemic.
- But Pfizer and Moderna
has said they still intend
to make a profit.
- We will not sell it cost.
- Kenneth Kayton from Tufts points out
that some pharmaceutical
companies with portfolios
of blockbuster drugs
should be able to absorb
the cost of the vaccine.
Sales from these products
can help take away some of
the pressure to profit from a
single Corona virus vaccine.
Meanwhile, the government is working
with commercial insurers as
well as Medicare and Medicaid
so people won't have to pay out of pocket.
There's also a government
plan to help fund
the vaccines for the uninsured.
Black and Latino
communities have less access
to health care than white people.
And they've been dying at
disproportionately higher rates
during the pandemic while
also making up a large part
of essential workers at
greater risk for exposure
to the virus.
So a free or affordable
vaccine would be one
of the best ways to
protect the most vulnerable
and return to some level of normalcy.
(gentle music)